as most like most careers I think if
you've done to a survey by fluke I
actually come from a family that has
always considered style and fashion my
father was in the rag trade so to speak
and my mother was quite stylish and
actually ended up working port time for
a boot local boutique when her kids were
all grown up and we were all burned up
and I done some work for some retail
stuff in my summer vacations from
boarding school in college but my first
job out of school was ironically to be
an assistant at glamour magazine and in
the fashion end of magazines I have
forever been well as I said I think
slightly swearing to my husband leaving
to go to my 98,000 fashion show in the
rain on Tuesday and we were chatting on
the phone I said it's all for the love
of clothes I do this all for loving
clothes and I think I was really one of
those girls I don't think I was I was a
clothes horse I just love clothes I love
dressing up I loved having lots of
clothes I we spent all of the money that
I earned on clothes that's kind of was
always on my wish list where things so I
left those
well I think the longer you stay in
various fields the pond becomes slightly
smaller particularly as you start to
rise up and get more experience and I
had previously to this job but living
with my English husband and one baby who
was born in London working for condé
nast title called Tattler which is kind
of a combination of Vanity Fair and Town
& Country loosely so slightly slightly
slightly socially oriented but with a
lovely sense of humor and great English
irony and wit to it which i think is its
unique selling point and got hired to I
think bring a bit of that social element
a bit of sort of New York reality to New
York Magazine and there you go
you